hello there it's becoming a ritual in
fortnight to celebrate a new season by
going over a few of the glitches the
game has to offer season 8 is no
different it's filled with weird and
wonderful glitches from hiding in stacks
of stone to getting under the map to
cheesing the slip stream so no one can
see you shoot do me a favor and use cold
adam arrow in the store and then sit
your butt down for 8 minutes and 51
seconds as we look at 8 season 8
glitches you need to see the first
glitch of the video i'm calling fortnite
horror mode and this one comes with a
challenge to you so get ready to act
your favorite creators season 8 brought
us the domes of darkness which spawn at
random spots each game if you ever see
the one at dirty docks be lined for it
to see this glitch when we enter the
domes two key things happen the visuals
change making things look more
horror-like and we also lose the ability
to build
now here's the glitch by finding this
wall here it's possible to trigger the
dome effect outside of that bubble check
it out fortnite just became a zombie
survival mode oh great they are in space
too visually this gives the entire
island a decaying effect with limited
lighting almost like fog there's some
impressive sights to take in but that's
not at all oh no remember when we said
we couldn't build inside the dome
this glitch also takes away that option
for the entire game if you trigger this
you will not be able to build and your
eyesight is now forcibly much worse so
that leads me to the challenge
can you and your team win a public game
of fortnite using this glitch no builds
and horror lighting
nikkei 30 muselk cipher pk i challenge
you win a game in this fortnight horror
mode okay after that epicness let's go
small with a glitch that doesn't impact
the game at all but it's funny to see
for this one you shall need to catch a
chicken and take it over to one of the
crash sites here you are looking for a
shadow stone simply consume it whilst
holding the chicken and enjoy this
useless glitch the chicken spins around
like a lunatic in a desk chair that's it
that that's that's that's the glitch
spinny chickens
i could honestly watch this all day here
it is again in slow motion next glitch
let's go under the island for this one
we are literally searching for a hole in
the map over on the right hand side of
the island all the way past the snowtop
campsite is this a missing slice of the
ground and by entering either building
or simply crawling through you'll be
officially out of bounds from here it's
possible to jump into the water below
and swim under the island watching
everyone above you i use a similar
method to check if epic have added any
underground elements in each update but
now there's a method for everyone there
is a caveat thankfully quickly after
this was found a death barrier was
created in public and competitive
matches which counts down to your death
in game if you deem to be a dirty
cheater and they have also disabled
building and shooting down here this
glitch is now only available in battle
labs so you don't have to worry about
losing a game to a dude under the map
hang on that's not totally true next
myth
this season we are doing what we did in
2018 watching a rolling cube of death
crush everything it stands against this
cube holds a strange glitch which lets
players survive a smash to the face and
live underground
when the cube started moving a few of us
couldn't resist their glow and became a
human sacrifice to the gods little did
we know the golden cube hits a bit
different there's a small chance that
instead of taking 10 000 points of
damage you'll instead be pushed under
the island at this point the death timer
we spoke of activates and a few seconds
later you'll officially seen too much
and be reduced to atoms an interesting
glitch but alas i don't think you'll be
winning many games like this
hang on what happens if the last two
players are crushed by a cube i bet the
glitch king has already tried this and
yes he has this is what happens
oh i stand corrected you can win games
by being crushed through the map the
more you know
our next glitch is from orange guy who
specializes in glitch videos around
fortnite so go subscribe to him right
now if that's your kind of thing he
shows us that it's possible to use
shadow stones to do something a little
bit trolly as we all know the shadow
stones let us phase through walls into
builds and buildings we can also phase
through trees and vehicles and rocks and
that's where the glitch is masterful at
many spots on the map there are these
types of rocks here not all of these but
some of these are possible to be phased
underneath and unlike other rocks which
explode when our shadow ability wears
off this rock type has the potential to
stay intact as long as we don't mess
with the hitbox too much like this right
now we can shoot from inside this rock
area and as long as we don't hit some of
the weak points we stay completely
hidden and can shoot everyone around us
and when they start shooting back they
have to get through the entire rock face
before they can hit you in replay mode
this is hilarious to look at so give
this a try when you get the chance and
just in case epic are watching epic i
only did this in battle labs and private
matches i haven't cheated please believe
me and i know to self i should wear a
smaller back bling i think it's giving
me away glitch number six the submarine
a returning glitch from last season is
back once again but this time it's more
op than ever before to try this simply
get a vehicle and go for a swim like
last season you'll slowly sink under the
waves but in season 8 the chances of
being ejected from your car are slimmer
and you can breathe underwater
indefinitely i've no idea why fortnite
logic let's call it it's now possible to
travel around driving underwater
relatively unnoticed too and the water
above your head will shield you from
most bullets and will also obscure the
view of you you can be hit though so
don't think you're invincible on the
flip side you can also shoot back and
hang out of windows whilst underwater a
quick note when you switch seats the car
will float back to the surface before it
slowly descends back to the bottom so be
sure to sit in the seat you want to be
in before you visit davey jones's locker
there are some ways to bend the rules in
fortnite without using glitches which
means even though the following aren't
intentional you won't be banned for
using them i'm sure you've already used
the shadow stones and then jumped into
the sky trails from the fallen ufos by
phasing into the air and keeping your
momentum going forward you can travel
across half the map all with the
knowledge that your glider will redeploy
and fall damage isn't an issue for you
although we're only one week into the
season i think this is the way most of
us get around now but wait if you're
ever in a fight whilst at these
locations be on the lookout for spots
like this a hidden area within the
slipstream which all but hides you from
enemies i mean look at this filth each
of the crashed abductors has many spots
like this which makes getting a cheeky
shot on a phone much easier and much
less stressful and hey if you get one of
those sweats which build the taj mahal
after one bullet you can simply stand
and watch
another legit glitch is getting on top
of the cubes around the world as you all
know if you try to touch one of these
cubes you are forcibly pushed away so if
you're shot from on top of one i don't
think many people would be expecting
that and also the cubes will be
traveling further away from the crash
sites which makes this strat even more
unexpected there are two ways to get on
top of a cube the first is by building
up to it and then walking onto the cube
slowly shooting your ramps to hide the
evidence
just remember though don't jump because
you will be thrown off again the second
method is to use a shadow stone the
trick is to use the phase ability the
exact moment you hit the cube which will
then transition you onto the cube some
leakers have suggested the cubes may be
getting a little bit higher from the
ground during the season like the golden
one right now and this makes the
shadowstone method the much easier way
to get on top although i have to know
the golden cube right now it moves it
oscillates which causes players to be
pushed off randomly and anyway all this
will be undone the day shooting the
cubes brings back their wrath remember
that from 2018 or the memories okay so
there we have it eight glitches for you
to be aware of in season eight please do
me a favor and give my fortnite horror
challenge a go and let's see if you can
win without builds in that horror film
lighting it's gonna be tough but i have
faith in you i'm adam you're awesome
here's a bunch of legends who use code
adam arrow this week thank you so much
for supporting me honestly it means the
world to me i'll see you next time
[Music]
you